[Musique]
le père jean baptiste honorât revo payer
dans les années 1840 l'église catholique
veut alors améliorer le sort des
canadiens français qui vivent sous
l'emprise des capitalistes anglais on
est alors en pleine révolution
industrielle
c'est la région du saguenay dominée par
une entreprise par des capitalistes qui
oeuvrent dans le domaine forestier donc
on parle de william price qui est
associé à peter macleod qu'on considère
comme le fondateur de chicoutimi et
d'autres d'autres agents donc qu'ils ont
on va dire un monopole économique sur la
région qui exploite dans différents sens
du terme donc la population des colons
de la région à la demande l'évêque de
montréal le père honorât s'installe à
laterrière en 1844 pour fonder la
colonie du saguenay une fois arrivée le
religieux fait construire un moulin à
scie qui deviendra plus tard un moulin à
farine
afin d'aider les canadiens français à
partir de 1846 il va fonder ce qu'on
appelle la colonne libre du gras brûlé
colonies qui serait installé ici à
laterrière sur des terres prometteuse
fini alors le paiement python et la
dépendance envers les anglais fonds
publics à cette époque là on paie les
gens avec les fans du piton donc des
salaires très bas qui seront pas payés
en argent donc sont dépendants des
établissements delà la compagnie des
pratiques aussi qui relève au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean cette époque là
d'un véritable far west c'est la loi du
plus fort n'y a pas d'institution de
justice donc c'est les plus forts qui
mène toutefois le moulin du père n'aura
ne restera pas en activité longtemps
confrontés à des compétiteurs de taille
la compagnie va rapidement devenir un
gouffre financier
cependant l'homme laissera ses idées en
héritage en plus d'un magnifique
bâtiment
c'est un
c'est toujours un défi d'aborder un
bâtiment historique je voulais trompe
toujours aujourd'hui aux abords de la
rivière du moulin
il a été abandonnée pendant de
nombreuses années avant d'être
transformé en maison
récemment encore l'architecte luc forte
elle a rénové en ayant le souci de
garder l'âme du bâtiment historique bien
vivante et nous lorsqu'on est intervenu
une dizaine d'années on a consulté les
photos historiques on voyait que
survienne le dollar n'y étant arrondis
comme la maison québécoise traditionnels
alors on s'est appliqué à reproduire les
détails le mieux possible pour rendre au
bâtiment sont l'apparence vraiment
d'origine
et puis le choix du cerd est tout tout
indiqué après avoir fondé veiller sur la
communauté laterroise le père n'aura
guère maintenant un oeil sont les
résidents du moulin que le moulin lui se
laisse enfin bercé par la rivière
après avoir connu des années beaucoup
plus mouvementée qui simili ça ça me
saoule et radio canada saguenay
[Musique]